[Applause]
Chancellor Angela Merkel's first stop in
Istanbul was the opening ceremony of the
new campus of a Turkish German
University Ankara and Berlin have
extensive cultural and economic ties but
the two nations are looking for a fresh
start and a new decade and their leaders
could be hoping 2020 brings about
progress on some prickly issues for
starters there's Libya's complex civil
war Turkish president reg AB type Oda
one took part in a peace conference in
Berlin earlier this month
having deployed troops to Libya Turkey
has become one of the key players there
that he used 2016 refugee deal with
Turkey will most likely be up for
discussion - under that agreement turkey
must stop migrants from crossing into EU
territory in exchange for billions of
euros to help look after the refugees at
hosts erawan has warned he can't uphold
his end of the deal if fighting in
Syria's Edler province causes more
people to flee Merkel though is likely
to urge her one to stick with the pact
finally Germany will probably seek
answers over the issue of German
nationals detained in Turkish prisons or
banned from leaving the country some
medjool Turkish nationals and have
suffered under the government's
crackdown on dissent following the
failed military coup three-and-a-half
years ago GWS Yulia Hahn is covering
Chancellor Merkel's visit to Istanbul
and she joins us for more hi Yulia good
to see you as we heard there there are
plenty of issues for these two leaders
to discuss tell us what's going to top
the agenda today
well yes the list of issues that might
potentially come up during today's that
talks between the German Chancellor and
president Edwin in the prom premises
right behind me here is quite long the
crisis in Syria in Libya in Iran but
from what we understand the so called a
migrant pact will be high on the agenda
the number of migrants trying to cross
into the European Union from Turkey
illegally has gone up sharply in recent
months in the past a year and there are
fears that the war in Syria's adlib
province could cause many more people to
flee and try to cross into Turkey now
this migration pact signed in 2016
between Ankara and the European Union is
looking more fragile the longer it is in
place
Turks president Aran has repeatedly
threatened to open the gates for
migrants to Europe as he put it
basically saying he can't shoulder the
burden of hosting nearly four million
refugees here in Turkey alone he is also
accused the you-you of not having paid
and sent the promised six billion euros
of aid money which the EU says is not
true now Chancellor Merkel on the other
hand has made this pact the core the
center of her migration policy so my
take is she's here in Istanbul today to
make sure turkey the Turkish president
is still committed to that deal Julia at
the same time relations between Germany
and Turkey have deteriorated over the
past few years what needs to happen to
improve those relations well some
visible attempts are being made today
just a little earlier the German
Chancellor and president edwin
inaugurated a new campus of the turkish
german university here in istanbul a
place where students from both countries
can study together merkel has called it
an extraordinary project of cooperation
edwin called her my dear friend but of
course these displays of harmony can't
hide the fact that there is a lot of
tension still there in this relationship
you've mentioned german citizens
allegedly for political reasons here in
turkish jails of press freedom freedom
of opinion have
commander attack here in Turkey
increasingly that's something the German
Chancellor has repeatedly criticized and
many here in Turkey but also at home and
Germany hope she'll find some clear
words today now the Turkish side on the
other hand has repeatedly accused
Germany of aiding terrorists of the
outlawed PKK for example so I think it
takes a lot and it's still a long way to
go until these relations between Germany
and Turkey can be called normal again
Yuli given that backdrop what concretely
do you think we can expect to come out
of today's meetings well I don't have
too high expectations there I'm not
expecting any breakthrough initiatives
to be announced but probably Chancellor
Merkel wants to take home a commitment
by adwin that he still upholds this
migration pact an add-on for himself
were pressed for political concessions
under this refugee deal for example visa
liberalisation for his citizens that's
something he has promised his citizens
that they can travel more easily into
the European Union
our correspondent Yulia Hahn reporting
there for us in Istanbul thank you